how are you both doing hey steve good
how are you
doing excellent uh i thought you guys
did such a great job with this film i'm
really happy to talk to you about it um
awesome uh so i i love the rashomon way
of telling this story and i'm just
curious when did you i'm not sure where
it was introduced in the script how did
you crack that code that you wanted to
tell it in that rashomon way
early on like early on before we even
decided to write it before i even
showed it to ben uh you know very very
early on um it just felt like the exact
right way to
tell this story um and uh
and which was great because you know
in terms of us begging nicole to come
right for with us like please come do
this um
we we we had that and the idea was and
ben actually did not beg me they did not
benefit
he had
ben was like this is going to be a six
week job yeah a month no he said it's a
month a month because he said it's one
act it's like 30 pages 35 pages like you
just crank this out and like you don't
even have to stop doing what you're
doing with your own movie like just just
come over and and help us and uh and two
years later we're still we're still here
talking about it and it's been great
yeah i think you guys thought it would
be more interesting than telling a
linear story yeah yeah and and and also
this idea of you know especially in this
day and age when people are constantly
talking about their own truths and my
truth and this perspective and that
perspective like let's tell the story
from these three different perspectives
because
particularly
character wasn't in that culture right
viewed as a human being she was viewed
as property uh legally she was property
she was the property of her father and
then she became the property of her
husband who was a man who was basically
her father's age the guy that i play and
and
this woman just kind of jumped off the
page in this book that we read that we
adapted this from
for just being so brave to kind of
in that in that culture to like speak
truth to power the way she did
um at the risk of so much eventually at
the risk of her own life she was just
awesome and so that's why we wanted to
make a movie about her yeah i'm very
happy you did also i think people need
to realize that you know in this day and
age it's tough for anyone to say the
word rape and the repercussions back
then that could be a death sentence
it's it's yeah and in fact eric in the
book that we base this on eric yeager
who wrote the book he talks about that
like the the first risk that she took
was telling her husband because
oftentimes the husband would just kill
would just kill them immediately right
and so it was like she had no legal
recourse without which we which she says
in the movie which was true
her husband had to take up the case and
had to take up this cause or she was not
she had no voice and uh and so the very
first risk she had to take was telling
him telling him and that's one of the
reasons that a lot of women stayed
silent was was just it was the safest
thing to do and men were often
compensated financially for to pay for
the embarrassment of their wives
uh having been raped having been raped
yeah yeah
oh um i like all of like everyone who's
gonna watch this and you guys i'm a huge
ridley scott fan and i'm just curious
when he signed on or agreed to do the
movie how did he collaborate on the
script if at all and you know what what
did he add to the the movie like if you
could just talk about collaborating with
him
well with ridley i mean it's it's uh i
mean he was involved with the script the
whole time we had a lot of meetings with
him and note sessions and even when i
was shooting the movie stillwater in
marseille nicole and ridley came over
and we had a weekend where we just sat
and went through the script you know and
what ridley's amazing at is is explain
like he'll he'll in 20 minutes he'll rip
off a watercolor you know because he's
an incredible fine artist and he and and
you'll see he's like i'm thinking
something like this and you'll see the
light source you'll see you go like okay
all right i understand the scene as as
we're gonna shoot it in a year you know
i i know you know and so you can kind of
he's so visual that uh
that
it's really helpful to talk it through
with him and he'll kind of show you
where he's going and then as an actor he
sits down and goes line by line through
it and he's able to tell well i'm gonna
start on your face i'm gonna start in a
close-up or i'm starting very wide here
and as a right it's good you go you can
kind of write to that and uh so it's
really a
um
you know a collaboration
anything you want to add nicole
no
i talk too much
i'm just going to say i really mean it
you guys did such a great job with this
uh and i'm glad you've been i'm glad you
spent 30 days working on it
yeah yeah exactly
it's a real treat
thank you so much